it's this theory I have which is that
Donald Trump may accidentally do some
good
not that he would even intend to do good
but that there may be some and and I'm
eternally looking for some reason for
there to be no no no no I listen he has
said I mean he has said things like he
said he'd never cut Medicaid yeah and
you know you saw the Republican health
care bill which is I'm glad we defeated
it
no no but there are issues that on
infrastructure he wants to do
infrastructure we need to build
infrastructure we need to have a modern
infrastructure 21st century
infrastructure in this country and that
that will create jobs he has said that
he wants to bring down the cost of
prescription drugs I have a very
comprehensive bill to do that I think
everybody in this audience has seen the
cost of pharmaceuticals just spiked in
the last three years there's reasons for
that we can address them and I hope we
do those in a bipartisan way we should
be able to I write about this in in the
book much of the stuff that I've been
able to accomplish only you can only do
in a bipartisan way that's the way it's
kind of supposed to work and we're going
to be taking up the healthcare you know
the exchanges on before in the
Affordable Care Act to strengthen those
to bring down the costs of premiums for
people in the health committee health
education labor and pension committee
which I sit on in the chairman Lamar
Alexander from Tennessee Republican I
know he wants to do that and we are
going to do that so there are things
that we can do and I want president
Trump to be successful in those areas
where I agree with them and I agree that
we need to have 21st century
infrastructure and I agree that we need
to get across the pharmaceuticals down
there's gonna be other stuff we agree on
all right
you